hi guys cam here what wait
Seb here Cam's taking a week off some
say the disappearance of the office copy
of FIFA is directly involved but I am
sure it's just a coincidence but while
he's been gone we've been playing the
vanishing of Ethan Carter a first-person
mystery game that's all about
exploration discovery and solving ghosts
crimes there are many things to love
about the game the fact that it doesn't
hold your hand the puzzle solving the
random astronauts the lot but what will
really get you is how absolutely
gorgeous and real the game looks without
even playing on an ultra high setting I
mean look at that grass those trees that
building so the whole thing got me
thinking how did the games developers
get such good looking assets and how can
video games become more photorealistic
so after some intense googling it turns
out the astronauts who are the guys who
made the game not some random spacemen
use a nifty technique called
photogrammetry to achieve that
real-world look photogrammetry is the
science of making measurements from
photographs and despite sounding super
space-age II it actually dates back to
the mid 19th century but nowadays modern
technology has streamlined the process
you start by taking a buttload of
pictures of your desired object from
every conceivable angle some objects
require as little as around 30 pictures
whereas bigger structures need a couple
of hundred then you plug the pictures
into some snazzy software like photo
scan by Adi soft which uses a big old
algorithm to make sense of it all so
after shoving a load of 2d images in you
get really highly detailed 3d models out
which you can then plunk into your game
after compressing the files a bit
because the ones the software throws out
are huge
photogrammetry has been used for years
for loads of various applications like
topographic mapping architecture and
engineering as well as cropping up in
movies like The Matrix the actors are of
course filmed using bullet time but the
background is a 3d model created by
using photos of the real-life set so
that's the basic pow but why would
developers want photo realism in their
games surely video games are all about
the whimsical fantastical places that
are impossible to visit in any other way
simulators aside that is well one of the
reasons is down to the uncanny or does
an Heimlich if you want the awesome
sounding german term it's a Freudian
concept which refers to when we see
something that feels both familiar and
alien at the same time causing an
internal conflict as we're both
attracted and repulsed by the object in
video games we frequently see this with
game characters who look 99% real and
it's referred to as the uncanny valley
well it sort of turns out that it
happens with textures in video games as
well our brain unconsciously rejects
these perfectly tiled textures even
though they're doing the job and it kind
of cuts you off from the immersion with
photorealistic assets such as the ones
gained from photogrammetry there's
nothing in your brain telling you that
this isn't right because they are real
another reason to use photogrammetry
comes down to the actual game
development process making assets for
games is an expensive and time-consuming
business not every studio has the
manpower of a company like Ubisoft who
has hundreds of people working on the
same game across the globe at any one
time for example take Assassin's Creed
unity movies developers rebuilt the
famous not sure Dom in Paris to a
one-to-one scale and spend upwards of a
year doing it that's really cool but
using that amount of time and resources
just to make assets simply isn't
feasible for a smaller studio instead of
painstakingly creating each asset taking
pictures of objects and letting the
software build it is much quicker plus
you capture all the small nuances like
cracks and erosion that an artist might
simply not have time to create so
photogrammetry is an awesome way of
creating fantastic looking assets but is
it the be-all and end-all is it going to
replace traditional game artists with
photographers and software well if we
come back to the vanishing of Ethan
Carter you'll see that it isn't strictly
speaking fully photorealistic after the
photogrammetry the team added stylized
lighting post-processing and
mixed in some traditionally made assets
but why because as the astronauts art
director Andre posnansky admits himself
they're making a dark weird fiction game
if the world doesn't match up with the
environment that we're seeing there'll
be some kind of dissonance which would
break up the immersion so it's likely
we'll see more photogrammetry now that
the software and technology is more
readily available but in order for
developers to really create those living
breathing environments to tell their
story in' the artist needs to add
character so to that end photogrammetry
is just a big useful tool in the artists
arsenal alright that's it for this week
folks but if you would like to try
photogrammetry yourself head over to the
agile software site right now where
they're offering a free trial of their
software oh and for more on the uncanny
valley that we talked about before you
should also have a look at cams previous
episode discussing our love-hate
relationship with zombies cam will be
off his couch and back in the studio
next week with more gamey science and
probably no small amount of RSI from all
that FIFA he's been playing in the
meantime you can catch me on Twitter at
Ready Steady Go thanks for watching
you